from real life romance to queer reunions
and real-life onset romance there's a
lot more to Chucky than stabbing Voodoo
and overalls is he really a good guy
after all
Chucky's character design has been
remarkably consistent over the decades
sure his plastic mug has had a few edits
here and there but overall his look has
remained undeniably reliable flaming red
hair denim overalls and of course those
icy piercing blue Peepers which are the
same color as those of Charles Lee Ray
actor Brad Dourif Chucky's ice blue eyes
as well as the rest of his look were
designed by creature effects artist
Kevin Yeager who worked on the first
three Child's Play films one of Jaeger's
other iconic Creations is the ghoulish
pun-loving host of the HBO Anthology
series Tales from the Crypt who shares a
certain feature in common with Chucky
indeed lodged inside the Crypt Keepers
sunken skull are a pair of expressive
blue eyes that once belonged to a
certain good guy
now that's Entertainment the list of
spooky predecessors who Inspire Chucky
is nothing to scoff at and his creators
are more than eager to cite their
sources one inspiration for the good guy
toys was an interactive talking doll
named Corky whose voice actor Edon gross
provided the good guy friendly voice
there are also striking similarities
between the good guy design and Hasbro's
My Buddy doll as well as the iconic
Cabbage Patch Kids the creators also
Drew inspiration from some notable
fictional killer dolls including Taki
Tina from an episode of The Twilight
Zone series and the notorious Zuni
Warrior doll from the Amelia segment of
the 1975 TV film Trilogy of Terror while
not a direct inspiration it's also worth
mentioning Chucky's real-life
counterpart dressed as a sailor and
standing at 40 inches tall Robert the
doll was supposedly infused with black
magic and Voodoo by a disgruntled family
made the rumored laundry list of creepy
occurrences associated with Robert
includes the doll wandering around in
the middle of the night rearranging
furniture and terrorizing family pets
how many special effects technicians do
you need to operate the puppet of a
deranged killer doll possessed by the
soul of a serial killer the answer at
least when it comes to the original 1988
Child's Play is 11 as executive producer
David kirschner revealed to Mental Floss
in 2019. the puppet featured in about
half of the film was radio controlled
and it utilized animatronic techniques
that were considered groundbreaking at
the time meanwhile three foot six inch
performer Ed Gale was used for broader
less subtle movements one of Chucky's
puppeteers was n Brock winkless IV who
also worked on Tales from the Crypt the
presence of puppeteers and practical
character effects work more broadly has
since become a trademark of the series
while some CGI has made its way into the
franchise over the years onset puppets
continue to play an integral part but
when action-packed wide shots are
required Chucky has been portrayed by
short statured actors and children the
most prolific of them is Ed Gale who
appeared in the original film as well as
Child's Play 2 and Bride of Chucky one
other notable Chucky stunt double in the
first movie was Alex Vincent's kid's
sister Ashley whom you can spot
sprinting around the apartment
terrorizing Maggie the babysitter have
you ever noticed how famous assassins
and serial killers often go by three
names like John Wayne Gacy John Wilkes
Booth and Mark David Chapman it's
perhaps fitting then that the full
government name of the murderous Child's
Play villain follows a similar pattern
as we know him as Charles Lee Ray
abbreviated to the less wordy Chucky
once he's in doll form Charles Lee Ray's
human name comes from three different
prolific Killers cult leader Charles
Manson John F Kennedy assassin Lee
Harvey Oswald and Martin Luther King Jr
assassin James Earl Ray with a nasty
moniker cobbled together from three
real-life Killers Charles Lee Ray sounds
evil for good reason
when you think about it a collaboration
between Chucky and a certain French
robot-headed electronic Duo feels like a
match made in heaven or perhaps hell
indeed if you're a Daft Punk fan there's
a good chance that you've had a peek
under Chucky skin without even realizing
it the band's music video for their song
Technologic features a series of pitch
altered phrases that seem to have
originated from a malicious doll with
exposed circuitry and false teeth as the
wireclad freak barks various
technological orders a seemingly more
naive skinless robot flanked by the
robot Duo looks on in awe considering
that the video for Technologic came out
in 2005 just one year after Seed of
Chucky it seems likely that this
particular skinless monster was created
by Tony Gardner and the crew over at
altarian Inc Gardner has worked numerous
Chucky projects as well as other Daft
Punk collaborations
every fan of the child's play franchise
loves Brad dourif's raspy
profanity-filled vocal performance as
Chucky but even though he sounds perfect
now his casting wasn't always part of
the plan before dorif signed on for the
original film the casting team
originally had someone very different in
mind believe it or not Jessica Walter
who's probably best known as Lucille
Bluth from Arrested Development almost
voiced the killer doll as director Tom
Holland revealed to mental flaws in 2019
she could make the threats work but not
the humor so we went back to Brad if
that's a veiled criticism about me I
won't hear it and I won't respond to it
the attempt at female casting was
actually inspired by one of the most
successful horror films of all time as
long time series writer Don Mancini
revealed on the Child's Play DVD
commentary track Tom's logic was that
the voice of the devil was done by a
woman in The Exorcist the debate to over
whether on-screen violence inspires
real-life violence is an age-old one as
legendary director John Carpenter put it
at a 2007 Tribeca Film Festival panel
real life causes violent acts fake life
does not censorship never works you can
hide you can try to cover it up but you
can't destroy it one particular study
from 2009 actually seemed to suggest
that horror movies may help stop violent
crimes but there are still some people
in the real world who take the concept
of Life imitating art to disturbing new
lows with that in mind it's worth noting
that in the early 90s Child's Play 3 was
cited as the inspiration for the
killings of Suzanne Capper and James
Bulger in the United Kingdom in response
to those tragedies director Tom Holland
told the independent that people who are
inspired to commit crimes by horror
movies were quote unbalanced to begin
with
in the original 1988 Child's Play
Charles Lee Ray uses a voodoo prayer to
transfer his soul into the plastic
prison of a nearby Good Guy doll over
the course of the franchise other
practitioners employ the chant for
similar purposes to Aid Chucky in his
quest to cheat death but Chucky's abuse
of voodoo magic wasn't always part of
the plan the script was at one point
titled blood buddy and in this version
the doll wasn't possessed by the voodoo
transferred soul of a serial killer as
Don Mancini explained to Mental Floss it
was a manifestation of a little boy's
unconscious rage his ID to explain how
the doll came to life Mancini devised an
especially gruesome scenario as he
revealed if you play too rough with him
his latex skin would break and he'd
bleed this red substance so you'd have
to buy special bandages so the boy Andy
in a Rite of Brotherhood cuts his thumb
and mixes it with the doll's blood and
that's the Catalyst that brings the doll
to life this idea was ultimately nixed
and as executive producer David
kirschner explained I wasn't sure
anybody would buy a doll with blood it
off
keeping score of how many people die in
horror movies might be a disturbing
hobby but that's what slasher movies are
all about with eight films as of 2023
Chucky certainly holds his own with the
deadliest of his slasher peers according
to a tally calculated by Screen Rant
he's racked up a total of 67 confirmed
kills that's not quite as many as other
horror icons like Jason Voorhees or
Michael Myers but Chucky nevertheless
still stands Head and Shoulders above
many of his peers even if that's not
literally the case one villain whom he's
notably deadlier than is
interdimensional Hell priest Pinhead
from Hellraiser which is certainly an
accomplishment for a serial killer
trapped in a two foot tall doll body any
fan of the franchise of course knows
about the fourth film Bride of Chucky in
which Chucky infamously gets lucky but
do you also know about the real life
romance inspired by child's play in the
original 1988 film Katherine Hicks plays
Karen Barclay mother of Andy during
production she met Kevin Yeager special
effects makeup artist and creator of the
Chucky doll and the two of them promptly
hit it off in a 2020 interview with ABC
7 Jaeger recalled that he'd been
scheduled to do Hicks makeup but she
eventually nixed the idea as she was
secretly afraid of letting a cute guy
see her skin so closely but it
eventually all worked out as they got
married in May of 1990 and they're still
going strong after more than 30 years of
marriage they have a daughter named
Caitlin and it's safe to say that no
other couple can beat them when they
talk about how they found love in the
strangest place
Chucky was never exactly meant to be gay
by Design but the franchise really took
a campy queer-coded turn in 1998's Bride
of Chucky and we have openly gay Chucky
Creator Don Mancini to thank for that
those subtle queer Vibes were really
brought to the Forefront in the 2004
follow-up Seed of Chucky that film
features our favorite killer doll
fathering a non-binary child named Glenn
Glenda a nod to Edward's notorious 1953
film Glenn or Glenda as Jennifer Tilly
recalled to Pride Source in 2017.
Universal said Seed of Chucky is too
funny it's too gay Don just basically
had a carnival of fun with that movie
while the next two sequels 2013's Curse
of Chucky and 2017's Cult of Chucky
played things a little more straight the
franchise returned to a gender-fluid
space when the character of Nika became
possessed by the soul of Charles Lee Ray
at the conclusion of Colt Nika possessed
by Chucky kisses Tiffany in human form
before driving off into a snow-filled
non-existent sunset
so this is different
I don't know
worse for me in October 2021 the
gruesome good guy got his very own TV
series for the first time in his decade
spanning career sci-fi's and USA
Network's Chucky follows the continuity
of the Child's Play movies overseen by
long time series writer Don Mancini and
the cast features several old returning
favorites from the films in general the
show is more serious and More tonally in
line with the first two films it's set
in a sleepy small town and revolves
around a teenage artist named Jake
played by Zachary Arthur after Jake
unwittingly purchases the possessed doll
at a yard sale the murders are quick to
follow a second season aired in 2022 and
it's enjoyed favorable critical reviews
the third season debuts in October 2023
father-daughter acting Duo Brad and
Fiona dorif have appeared on screen in
the child's play Universe multiple times
and the Chucky TV show offers an all-new
twist to this collaboration Fiona first
appeared in the franchise as the
terminally unlucky Nika Piers who is the
final girl and Curse of Chucky and the
final girl possessed by Chucky in Colt
of Chucky on the Chucky TV show the
title doll is still living rent-free in
Nika's mind and watching Fiona play both
Nika and the Chucky possessed Tanika is
a treat to behold and there's a
flashback scene in season one featuring
Fiona in which Charles Lee Ray meets
Tiffany that's truly mind-blowing Fiona
already looks a lot like her dad to
begin with but she's styled to look
exactly how he did when he first played
Charles in the original child's play
Brad then dubbed Fiona's dialogue for
the scene and the result is demented and
delightful as Fiona explains to Bloody
Disgusting it's like an Instagram face
mash app except you can't get it off I
facetimed my dad as my dad it was really
weird that's all I got it's weird
I'm Tiffany
I'm Charles
Don Mancini set out to expand Chucky's
audience to young adults with the Chucky
TV show part of that goal is
accomplished by lacing a sweet gay love
story between two teens Into the Heart
of the show as well as by showing how
the bullied ultimately triumph over
their bullies as Mancini explained to
den of geek in 2021 the culture of
bullying that exists in recent years
among today's youth is in itself a true
life Horror Story we use Chucky as a
metaphor as the ultimate bully he is
charming and he's funny bullies can
appear to us in that guise and be
seductive throughout the course of the
child's play series Chucky tries to get
kids who feel oppressed some relief by
letting them help him kill their
oppressors it works out in Chucky's
bloody favor about half the time but the
real Triumph comes from watching the
teens like Jake resist Chucky's lure to
the dark side as Mancini told the
advocate when Chucky ends up in a kind
of weird toxic bullying relationship
with Jake one of the ways he's able to
manipulate this kid is by ironically
expressing a kind of empathy and
sympathy for him Chucky might not
exactly be a true Ally but as Mancini
explains he's not homophobic and he's
not a bigot he's an equal opportunity
killer the ins and outs of Chucky's
seemingly Immortal Soul can get a little
confusing especially when the heroes are
faced with multiple Chuckies whether
slivers of Charles Lee Ray's Soul are
showing up in good guy dolls surviving
victims or an entire Army the mythology
behind how all of this works isn't
always clear but Don Mancini has at
least clarified that Chucky's
manifestations are distinct and not one
entity an army of Chuckies always
appealed to him though as he admitted to
Bloody Disgusting it's definitely not a
hive mind he further explained I
considered both Avenues when I started
putting this together it's something
that I wanted to do for a while once you
get into your fourth decade in a
franchise it's trying to forge ahead
into unseen unexplored territory so all
of the various versions of Chucky are
all different sides of the same killer
coin according to Mancini one reason for
this is to Showcase Brad dourif's varied
performances as he explained where
dissecting the Persona of Chucky and the
Persona of Charles Lee Ray we have many
different versions of that in the season
and many different actors playing
Charles Lee Ray or Chucky
your boxes all of you Chucky is a killer
doll who refuses to die and he's also
kept plenty of character actors careers
alive when Jennifer Tilly heard about
the Chucky TV show she expected her part
in it to just be a cameo instead Don
Mancini wrote her a deep and layered
character that essentially rebooted her
career on the show Tilly plays Tiffany
Valentine as well as a fictionalized
version of herself and the series even
dramatizes the bloody first meeting
between Tiffany and Charles Lee Ray
Tiffany's journey through death and
destruction and maybe even better
romantic choices is one that the real
Tilly is thankful for as she reveals to
Bloody Disgusting sometimes you get put
in a box when you're an older actress I
don't know what parts there are for all
the women because I never get offered
them Don and I are of similar age I'm
one of his best friends so we hang out
all the time he just sees me as Jennifer
Tiffany is just this really campy
character that's a killer but has a very
good fashion sense I liked that he gave
her some really dramatic scenes this
season and last and you can dig your
teeth into her Chucky is constantly
Reinventing himself from Hardcore
Slasher in the original Child's Play to
Gothic romance and Bride of Chucky and
all the horror comedy hijinks of cult of
Chucky and Seed of Chucky Don Mancini is
clearly not afraid to explore new
approaches so it's both a total surprise
and no surprise at all that one episode
of the Chucky series acts as a
standalone Agatha Christie style Murder
Mystery episode 4 of season 2 entitled
death on denial is the whodunit in
question it comes complete with multiple
celebrity guest stars who all point the
finger and possibly the butcher knife
that guest cast includes Jennifer
Tilly's bound co-stars Gina Gershon and
Joe pantoliano as well as her real-life
sister Meg Tilly as Mancini revealed to
Entertainment Weekly Jennifer was not
surprisingly extremely instrumental in
helping put all of that together I had
coincidentally met Gina before I ever
met Jennifer back in the 90s to be able
to reunite that cast and work with them
is kind of a queer fever dream come true
honestly it is nice seeing all your
sweet faces former 90s teen dream and
current 40-something hunk Devon Sawa has
been a critical part of the Chucky TV
show in multiple roles way before Chucky
came his way he was already a major name
in the horror genre as he starred in
1999's Idle Hands and 2000's Final
Destination as well as the lesser-known
and more recent fright flick hunter
hunter in season one of Chucky saw what
plays Jake's angry abusive father Lucas
as well as Jake's angry differently
abusive Uncle Logan Chucky manipulates
Lucas's bad treatment of Jake to try and
bring out some homicidal tendencies in
the kid though he has slightly more
success elsewhere in the family Sawa
returned for season 2 as father Bryce a
Catholic priest whom Chucky manages to
get quite close to in the end as the
actor explained to Entertainment Tonight
this new guy is less toxic than the
first two guys but he still has some
stuff going on Sawa is also set to
return for season 3 in a whole new venue
for Chucky to haunt specifically the
White House and as the actor is now
going to play the president of the
United States we sure hope he keeps the
nuclear launch codes on the highest
shelf in the Oval Office let's just see
the Oval Office even though Chucky has
made the move to TV he certainly isn't
ready for prime time the devilish doll
has quite the famously filthy vocabulary
after all and Don Mancini wouldn't have
it any other way the rider credits NBC's
Hannibal another movie to TV franchise
that he worked on for inspiring Chucky's
Scurry to the small screen as well as
helping keep the show True to its
R-rated Roots as he explained to
Entertainment Weekly before we even sold
the show we had to confirm with the
network that Chucky could drop his
f-bombs Mancini noted that Chucky gets a
maximum of 10 f-bombs per episode which
stands in stark contrast to what
director Steven Spielberg got for Chucky
when the doll made a cameo appearance in
the 2018 movie Ready Player one as
Mancini recalled since that was a PG-13
they had one mandated F-bomb at their
disposal and Spielberg chose to deploy
it with Chucky's appearance which I
loved
[__] Chucky Chucky is quite the
improvisational killer doll he goes with
the flow and uses what resources he has
available to him just like his human
counterpart Charles Lee Ray did before
him now does this mean that the child's
play franchise is riddled with certain
plot holes and inconsistencies sure but
at least those plot holes and
inconsistencies are fun bloody and bound
to give viewers a migraine when
explanations are offered decades later
season one of the Chucky TV show does
its best to clear up why Charles can
seemingly only transfer his soul into
good guy dolls the entire franchise has
played with the idea of Chucky drawing
on the powers of voodoo and other
ill-defined magic to move his rotten
Soul around like day Traders move money
it's also toyed with the concept that
Chucky is powered by rage and sacrifice
but the season one finale explains that
because Charles Lee Ray used a certain
spell in the original Child's Play to
transfer his soul into a good guy doll
anytime that he uses the same spell
afterwards he must also use an identical
Garbage Pail so to speak to house his
soul does this fully explain why he can
sometimes Splinter himself up into
certain human bodies perhaps not but
maybe the writers will explain that in
another episode down the line or just
leave it as a happy and hilarious
mystery
Chucky is a Relentless remorseless
killing machine even when he was a human
he was depraved and destructive so could
there have ever truly been a time when
Chucky was good the answer is kind of
and it happens in season two of the
Chucky TV show in this chapter of the
franchise Jake and his friends capture
Chucky and try to brainwash his violent
tendencies away it's reminiscent of a
similar scene in the 1971 film A
Clockwork Orange in the Chucky version
the process actually works at least for
a little while good Chucky is sweet
innocent and so disgusted by violence
that it makes him puke the result is so
effective that it even scares the teens
we didn't brainwash him we brain
bleached him it's a take on the
character that Brad Dourif absolutely
loves even if good Chucky was ultimately
destined to break bad again still it
might not be curtains for good Chucky
forever even after all that transpires
in season two as Don Mancini revealed in
an interview I don't know that we've
necessarily Seen the Last of him just
because I think I may need to see more
of that just because I enjoy it you know
and I know Brad enjoys it to promote
season 3 of the Chucky TV show the
killer doll has hosted a press
conference and it's exactly as vulgar as
you'd expect in the clip Chucky takes to
the Too Tall Podium to address a very
curious press Corps this latest batch of
episodes is set in Washington DC and
stars Devon Sawa as the President of the
United States though Chucky refuses to
acknowledge that he even knows who the
actor is well Devin Sawa be returning as
a new character Chucky can't stop
slinging SASS and profanity at all of
the gathered reporters he's
understandably grumpy as the
announcement is cutting into his
precious time for terrorizing he's
clearly upping the ante and fight
against Jake wheeler and friends and
America in general by moving his
headquarters to the nation's capital
however he refuses to answer almost any
of the questions asked of him by the
press for a killer doll who seems to
Crave attention he could really stand to
brush up on his PR skills perhaps the
events of season 3 will include Chucky
assembling a Communications team of his
very own maybe he could even take
inspiration from Megan and show off a
dance that is sure to go viral over the
years quite a few things have proven to
be true about Chucky and one in
particular is that he's always down to
learn something and kill someone new
foreign
[Music]